what an odd sentence one congressional
candidate quoted in that piece jennifer
ruth green joins us now jennifer ruth
good to see you now
first of all i want to go back to what
was said
in the angle tonight about democrats
believing
that african americans don't have
apparently the capacity to get voter id
at the same level as others your
reaction to that first off
wow
in this country we need ids for
literally everything and it's honestly
insulting
to say that black americans can't get
ids won't get them it's just a trojan
horse and another hat trick to continue
to politicize race that we consistently
see from the top and the elites and the
democrats consistently striving to use
race to pander they're not focused on
the clear things like election integrity
they're just focused on getting
democrats elected and it's shameful
what do americans tonight watching need
to know about changes in the electorate
especially
as democrats as newt gingrich said
they try to paint this picture as
republicans or independents as pro-putin
what are they talking about like they're
pro-putin or it's putin gas hikes or
blaming fox
never looking in the mirror what do
americans need to know about the
changing black voting landscape
black people
african americans we are not a monolith
right and you can't just continue to
conceptualize us as a single factor
we are not stupid and we see the clarity
of all of the failures that continue to
exist we see the the crazy skyrocketing
of prices we see the energy costs that
we're continuing to pay for we see the
poor border security we see the poor
international relations and that's
continuous and so black voters are not
stupid and as we continue to focus uh
just in general about seeing how 18
months ago we were better off as a
country we're going to continue to see
black voters re-engage and see and focus
on the truth now i want to play
something from an old friend of yours al
sharpton um here's how he says that the
democrats uh need to get the message out
to black voters watch
when you talk to black voters you did
not get the john lewis bill passed we
did not get the george floyd justice
bill passed but what did we do well
biden put more blacks on the
federal courts than all presidents
combined nobody knows that you've got to
put your message out there and what
we've done why it makes a difference
what it means to you at home not the
washington beltway crowd
jennifer ruth is that the right message
for african-american voters
absolutely not
the focus has to be on we kept our
promises we did what we were supposed to
do and america is better for it and 100
president biden and democrats and
liberal elites cannot say that nancy
pelosi frank murvan president biden
they're all on the same page
extensive failures and a clear lack of
vision for our country and they cannot
get away from being the scapegoats that
they are for the decisions that they've
made and that approach will not work
because once again black voters are not
ignorant to the realities of the
situations we face in america yeah high
gas prices high food prices are you
better off than you were three years ago
two if they're going to say no they're
that's just simple questions simple
question and they're losing every time
jennifer ruth thank you we'll be
watching the race closely hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else